en m'accueillant messieurs dans votre
compagnie que votre illustre fondateur
voulu lieu de mémoire et de défense de
la culture française
en me plaçant quel signe du destin dans
la lignée de Corneille de Victor Hugo du
Maréchal Lyautey du contre-bernard court
pour ne citer que vous avez répondu aux
rêves de l'enfant que je fus
la parole de ta madame Carrère d'encause
pour la lecture de son remerciement
messieurs
autant aux gens Missler qui fut plus
tard secrétaire perpétuel de votre
compagnie était tenue pour un espoir de
la Troisième République une enfant qui
était chaque année avec anxiété le
retour de l'automne et la rentrée
scolaire
dans ces classes que le souvenir
d'Augustin mauln en tête encore ou
flottait une douce odeur de craie et
d'encremêler le jour de la rentrée les
institutrices commençaient l'année par
le rituel initiatique presque de la
pelle
au moment de répondre à l'appel de son
nom l'enfant a été aimé comme Alice
disparaître dans quelques terriers car
toutes les têtes soudains tournaient
vers elles
exprimaient alors les jaillissement voir
la réprobation lui signifiant ainsi que
le nom entendu un nom un prononçable
venu du fond du Caucase
l'excluait de la communauté des
descendants des fiers Gaulois à
tetrondes il fallait chaque année des
jours voir des semaines pour effacer peu
à peu la pression des tranchéesuites
parce qu'institutrice et élève confondue
appelé son détour un nom à coucher
dehors
et tenez-vous messieurs d'apprendre que
le rêve le plus constant le plus cher de
cet enfant
fut de pouvoir par un miracle subit
remplacer un patronyme encombrants et
barbares par celui combien en viable du
bois ou durant pour pouvoir revendiquer
de plein droit
l'appartenance à la communauté scolaire
qui était en dernier ressort la
Communauté française
à défaut d'obtenir par un don soudain du
ciel cette intégration patronymique
l'enfant venu d'ailleurs s'approprier à
la France la patrie d'accueil des siens
la patrie choisie et par là
passionnément aimé en absorbant avec
avidité ce qui en était l'essentiel la
littérature et l'histoire
le jour où votre compagnie le reçu
Voltaire lui dit c'est le plus grand de
vos premiers académiciens ces corneilles
seuls qui commencent à faire respecter
notre langue des étrangers
précisément dans le temps que le
cardinal de Richelieu commençait à faire
respecter la couronne l'un et l'autre
portèrent notre gloire dans toute
l'Europe
en m'accueillant messieurs dans votre
compagnie que votre illustre fondateur
voulut lieu de mémoire et de défense de
la culture française
en me plaçant quel signe du destin dans
la lignée de Corneille de Victor Hugo du
Maréchal Lyautey du contre-bernard court
pour ne citer que vous avez répondu aux
rêves de l'enfant que je fus
vous m'avez donné le droit de me sentir
pleinement membre en leur lieu le plus
prestigieux de la communauté spirituelle
et de la tradition de la France
pour cette grâce dont vous avez je crois
compris la portée permettez que du fond
du cœur je vous remercie
vous donnez messieurs à ceux que vous
appelez à vous rejoindre un précieux
privilège celui de l'immortalité
ouvrez je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faille
trop tenté d'en vérifier le sens mais
l'immortalité nous autorisant tout cas
dans cette dorsale glorieuse ou les
vivants et ceux qui les ont précédés ce
preste ensemble à rappeler qui nous
plaît du Royaume des Ombres
j'ai évoqué à l'instant les noms de
quelques-uns de mes prédécesseurs
leur est venue de me tourner vers celui
qui vous fut à tous si proches
Jean mystère
je me demande si toute la philosophie de
l'histoire n'a pas été résumé par
Héraclide dans son pantaray non pas
hélas comme l'eau d'un fleuve qui glisse
paisiblement entre ses rives mais comme
les flots furieux d'une inondation
chariant des arbres déracinés et des
bêtes crevées
existe-t-il un refuge un asile peut-être
mais je trouvais
dans ces lignes
jean-micheler a rassemblé à leur
crépusculaire où l'homme regarde
derrière lui toute sa vie telle qu'il la
percevait
avec lui aujourd'hui je vais tenter
messieurs puisque vous m'avez fait
l'honneur de me placer en son aval de
remonter le cours d'une existence qui
fut longue de scruter ce que furent ces
hommes et les d'une vie et d'une œuvre
à l'origine l'écrira Jean-Michel il lieu
le bout du monde la fin de l'univers
connu la porte du monde féérique des
gazons de montagne qui sonnent crus sous
les pas des souterrains dont l'entrée
est perdue mais qui s'ouvrent avec leurs
trésors la nuit de Noël juste pendant
que seuls les douze coups de minuit
c'est là à quelques kilomètres de ce
bout du monde magique que jean-micheler
est né dans les toutes dernières années
d'un siècle encore léger qui a laissé la
place un siècle de bruit et de fureur et
surtout d'horreur
l'enfant il perd de l'homme et ses
premières années orientent toutes sa vie
et mettent-ils à dire c'est pourquoi il
faut nous souvenir des lieux et des
visages de sa prime enfance
Sorèze la Montagne Noire qui domine tout
le mystère du bout du monde et d'abord
le visage d'une mère aimée qui a porté
tout le poids de son éducation et qui
musicienne dans l'âme lui ont les gars
l'amour passionné et le don le paysage
fantastique du bout du monde
et la musique on sans aucun doute
puissamment contribue à développer en
lui le sens du mystère un esprit qui
sans cesse
atte au-delà du visible pour se projeter
dans l'invisible et dans le surnaturel
se présentant devant votre compagnie
messieurs comme je le fais aujourd'hui
Jean-Michel nourrit-il pas son
remerciement en évoquant Mozart et
l'entrée du prince Tamino dans le monde
des initiés
serait-ce ce fut aussi le collège dont
le Père Lacordaire disait serait une
école où la religion les lettres les
sciences les arts c'est-à-dire le divin
le vrai le réel le beau et les meubles
se partagent les heures d'un jeune homme
et se disputent son cœur afin de jeter
en lui les fondements si difficiles et
si complexes d'une vie d'homme
parce qu'il fut heureux à Sorèze Jean
bistler lui reste à fidèle toute sa vie
il présidait l'association de ses
anciens élèves et il y revint autre
voyage initiatique
célébrer ses 80 ans
bonheur rééducation allée de père à 13
ans et 10 mois Jean Missler était en
état d'être bachelier les tâches argées
de ce qui s'appelait encore en ce temps
l'instruction publique ce scandalisa de
cette précocité les prodiges ont
rarement bonne presse et Jean bissler
fut renvoyé pour un an sur les bancs de
l'école
moins de deux ans plus tard baccalauré
en poche il devint
il lieu pour camarade d'études un
certain Marcel da élève brillant obsédé
par le désir de refondre la société
mais pas plus en i4 que plus tard à la
Chambre Jean-Michel ne fut attiré par
desa en revanche son professeur de
philosophie Alain sur lui une influence
incontestable c'est avec lui qu'il
découvrit la philosophie et aussi le
radicalisme
faut-il s'étonner Cassie formé serait et
Henri IV se complétant Jean-Michel et
franchitrions falmant tous les obstacles
universitaires reçus à l'École normale
puis premier à l'agrégation de l'être
classique il semblait promise à
l'enseignement
mais entre l'arrivée en Cagne et
l'agrégation la guerre avait marqué sa
vie d'une trace indélébile le très jeune
canieu était d'un coup devenu un ancien
dans une classe vidé de ses élèves les
plus âgés par qui se faire tuer sur les
champs de bataille
à cette vie à l'arrière intolérable
Jean-Michel n'était pas un héros
dradiguet il préféra le destin des
appeler c'est là entre champs de
bataille et centre de formation
universitaire improvisée qu'il prépare à
les grands concours et il réussit
brillamment
pour autant il n'effacera jamais de sa
mémoire le souvenir de la boue des
tranchées encombré des morts et des
agonisants des cris des blessés du
désespoir des survivants
si l'artilleur jean-misler a conservé à
l'égard de la guerre une infinie pudeur
d'expression c'est dans les cœurs et non
sur le papier que le souvenir doit en
demeurer et créera-t-il plus tard elle
le entra toujours et cette obsession
explique bien de ses engagements à venir
comme bon nombre d'anciens combattants
il aura pour secrète de vise jamais plus
et il s'efforcera inlassablement de la
faire prévaloir dans son action publique
pour cet homme de réflexion puis
d'engagement était-il possible d'oublier
le prix que la guerre avait coûté à son
pays
génération fauchée société épuisée et
par-dessus tout société privée
d'espérance et de projet ou plutôt qui
en guise de projet allait se reposer sur
l'illusion que l'Allemagne vaincue
devrait être indéfiniment payé
avant l'entrée en politique au sortir de
l'enfance et d'une trop brève
adolescence il y eut pour jean-michelet
aussi une courte période de Faurie le
jeune agrégé allait-il devenir un
docteur dans quelques lycées provincial
la guerre avait fait de lui un homme
trop vite mûr pour un destin si sage le
service des œuvres à l'étranger en
s'être des relations culturelles
d'aujourd'hui lui offrit d'enseigner le
français à Budapest
c'est ainsi qu'un soir de l'année 1920
Jean-Michel
âgé de 23 ans fier possesseur d'un FRAC
payé comptant ou tailleur et berlué de
temps de largesse encombré d'une lourde
mal dont partitions des livres
représenter l'essentiel monta à bord de
l'Orient-Express pour conquérir l'Europe
centrale univers avant tout pour ce
mélomane passionné de Schubert et de
Mozart
mais la Hongrie ou le déposa
l'Orient-Express était bien éloigné de
ses rêves la guerre était passée par là
laissant derrière elles sont cortège de
désastre et par surcroît la défaite
l'humiliation
Jean-Michel il découvrit d'un coup
l'inflation galopante qui décompose
l'ordre social la pénurie devenant
misère extrême les croque-morts
portaient sous les sous le bras des
petits cercueils d'enfants semblables à
des boîtes à violon une atmosphère de
deuil et de détresse infinie voilà ce
qui est début d'apaise en 1920
pour autant Jean mystère n'y fit pas un
séjour déplaisant bien au contraire il
avait pour y être heureux toutes les
raisons il était beau et hongroises
étaient ravissante et son charme dont
vous avez été témoin messieurs car il
n'abandonna jamais valut à cet homme qui
aimait tant les femmes
sauf à l'Académie
de très nombreux succès
il dirige de surcroît car le front de la
France victorieuse avait bonne
réputation dans un pays dont la monnaie
se déprécier dort en heure
tout était donc facile à ce jeune homme
aimé des dieux et de romans exquis et
crise à son retour château en Bavière et
était le cas perpétueront le souvenir de
deux ombres légères qui illuminèrent son
séjour sans peser sur sa vie
roman du souvenir de la reconnaissance
du cœur mais aussi chronique de ce que
Stéphane vaig décrira par ailleurs le
monde d'hier et la nostalgie d'une
civilisation qui se défait
c'est à Budapest aussi que Jean-Michel
se découvrait la vocation du chant doté
d'une belle voix de ténor et d'une
exceptionnelle mémoire musicale il fut
sa vie durant capable de chanter tout
l'oeuvre de Schubert les duos de l'opéra
italien les opéras de Wagner
abudapest il fit sur scène des débuts
retentissants en chantant
n'est-ce pas la messieurs un signe
mystérieux du destin la belle Hélène
mais Jean Missler ne sait pas contenter
d'être en Europe centrale la coqueluche
des salons il fut aussi et surtout un
observateur attentif du monde qui
l'entourait et il fit de la tentative
manquée du roi Charles de Hongrie pour
reprendre son trône un récit digne d'un
historien
s'est équipé royal qui a trouvé place
dans le jeune homme qui rôde et denses
de l'importance de ce séjour dans sa
formation
jean-mystère entrevoit alors toute la
fragilité d'une Europe centrale privée
de ses structures traditionnelles de ces
repères géographiques de ces certitudes
morales de manière encore intuitive il
comprend que cette partie du continent
européen qui flotte entre un passé à
jamais détruit et un avenir
indéchiffrable pour être bien se livrer
à l'aventure et aux aventuriers
quand sa chèvre en 1924 le séjour
hongrois la chance s'y présente dans les
stades jean-micheler lui sourit à
nouveau il succède au service des œuvres
à Pôle Morand et il y a pour voisins de
bureau aux gens Giraudoux
ouvrez tant de chance leur en suspect ne
serait-il pas le fils naturel d'Aristide
Briand voilà qui expliquerait
l'irrésistible ascension de cet homme si
jeune ou bien encore est-il franc-maçon
si l'évoquera parfois en souriant ces
rumeurs
dira sur tout avec force la
reconnaissance et la fidélité qu'il voit
toujours à brillant
au fonctionnaire en dépit de son jeune
âge Jean-Michel a pu combiner
durablement fonction culturelle et
activités littéraire pourtant c'est le
moment où va s'interrompre un destin
aussi brillant que paisible car la
politique fait alors irruption dans sa
vie
après l'enfant la guerre et le
vagabondage européen l'entrée dans la
vie publique ouvre pour jean-micheler
une existence nouvelle passionnante sans
doute puisqu'ici est donné complètement
et qui en l'espace de 12 ans lui fera
parcourir tout le cycle des triomphes
faisait des revers l'eau de la plupart
des destinées politiques
au milieu des années 20 le département
de l'Aude se souvient soudain d'une
étrange histoire en 1828 une certaine
Madame Lenormand piti célèbre priait de
prédire les résultats des élections pour
le siècle à venir fit une réponse
sibyline Carcassonne prendra l'homme de
Blois blasé et Castelnaudary le jeune
homme qui rôde
la méthode valait bien semble-t-il nos
sondages
le Parti radical pilier de la Troisième
République que l'on soupçonne rarement
d'une telle fantaisie entre voit alors
que le jeune homme qui rôde existe bel
et bien et qu'il peut faire un candidat
remarquable
jean-mystler car c'est de lui qu'il
s'agit est enfant du pays il parle le
patois du Lauragais conditions
nécessaires au temps où la télévision
n'avait pas encore remplacé les harangs
dans les préaux d'école et il était le
camp du coup le voilà être misé si les
choux en 1925 a emporté la mairie de
Castelnaudary il triomphe aux élections
1928 pourtant défavorable au radicaux
mieux encore dès cette époque il devient
l'un des principaux animateurs du
Mouvement des Jeunes Turcs qui
s'efforcent d'arracher le parti
valoisien à ses ornières de le rénover
de l'adapter aux besoins d'une France
encore brisée par la guerre les
nullements préparés au défi qu'il
attendent
ces jeunes turcs jeunes hommes
impatients turbulents rénovateur
ces qualificatifs indiquent bien le
regard paternel et inquiet que le parti
jette sur eux ont presque tous laissé
leur marque dans l'histoire politique
française du milieu du siècle
au tournant des années 30 les plus
connues et remuant d'entre eux se
nomment outre Jean Missler pierre cotte
Jacques Kayser Pierre Mendès France Jean
Zay Léon Martineau des plat
ils ont en commun d'appartenir à la
génération de la préguerre marquée par
le souvenir des horreurs des champs de
bataille et le mort ne constate une
victoire que l'état de la société prive
de ses chances de durée ils sont des
réalises un différents outils
comme les diffèrent de la première
génération dominée encore par Édouard
Herriot formé sous l'influence de
l'affaire Dreyfus et qui s'en tient à
une vision idéologique et idéale de la
France mais les vétérans savent que les
jeunes turquent leur sont nécessaires
parce que leur discours correspondent
aux inquiétudes et aux aspirations de
leur contemporains
hanté par le souvenir de cette guerre
qui fut leur véritable université les
jeunes turc rejettent le nationalisme et
trois il plaide ardemment pour les
États-Unis d'Europe dans le pilier
principal serait le couple
franco-allemand ils disent que la France
souffre d'un défaut d'état et réclame un
exécutif fort des assemblées enfin
représentatives des forces sociaux
économiques il plaide pour une économie
modernisée contrôlée en partie par
l'État et orienté en même temps vers la
défense de la propriété privée ni
communisme ni capitalisme débridé
proclame-t-il
sans doute les Jeunes Turcs ne sont-ils
pas seuls à tenir ce discours
qui fait partie de ce que Jean Touchard
si cher au cœur de tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'histoire des idées
appelées l'esprit des années 30 mais
plus que d'autres ils ont été et
jean-micheler est à cet égard
représentatif du mouvement conscient que
tous les vous fondements de la
civilisation européenne était alors
remise en cause et que dans ce
bouleversement moral et spirituel il
fallait d'abord songer à reconstruire la
société française
en très peu d'années le jeune député de
l'eau devient une défigures de prout
cette tendance les élections de 1932
sont triomphal pour son parti Jean
Missler a 35 ans devient ministre il le
sera trois fois avant de présider la
commission des affaires étrangères cette
spectaculaire ascension d'un homme si
jeune suggère à ceux qui le voient
avancer à grandes enjambées vers des
responsabilités toujours plus hautes
qu'il pourrait bien un jour se retrouver
à l'Élysée
pourtant par deux fois les événements
tragiques qui vont atteindre l'être même
de la France et qui tueront en 1940 la
République seront aussi les tragédies
personnelles de Jean-Michel il briseront
sa trajectoire foudroyante et en feront
un homme foudroyé
c'est d'abord le 6 février 1934 et le
massacre de la place de la Concorde
la France n'est plus si sûr alors
d'avoir gagné une paix éternelle
l'Allemagne hier vaincu redevient un
état menaçant acharné à effacer tous les
signes de la défaite
la France des années 30 peut-elle faire
face à la montée des périls certes non
elle est confrontée à une crise
politique grandissante à l'instabilité
gouvernementale à une crise économique
dont on commence à découvrir les effets
et surtout au discrédit croissant de la
république parlementaire éclaboussé par
des scandales à répétition
les adversaires du régime que le mot de
République révulse n'hésite pas à
s'attaquer aux institutions et en
appeler à la rue
Gustave Hervé écrit ce n'est pas le
balai que les mieux intentionnés de nos
parlementaires pourraient prendre pour
nettoyer les écuries de Marianne qui les
rendraient propres après les saletés que
le régime y a déposé depuis près de 50
ans il n'y a plus qu'une grande vague
populaire pour les laver et les nettoyer
le 6 février 1934 a été l'événement le
plus sanglant que Paris est connu depuis
la commune 15 morts près de 1500 blessés
en ordonnant d'ouvrir le feu sur les
manifestants Jane frou ministre de
l'Intérieur revue à l'urgence et pense
sauver la République mais les choses ne
sont pas si simple le chef du
gouvernement Édouard Daladier est certes
soutenu par la chambre mais ses amis les
plus proches lui conseillent la
démission et se démettent de même c'est
le 4 Jean-Michel
ce bain de sang lui est une tragédie
personnelle qui le marquera jamais
l'enfant prodige de la politique
l'adolescent rénovateur dont les succès
foudroyants semblaient ne devoir jamais
s'arrêter voilà qu'on le traite soudain
de galopin sanglant
se qualifie se qualificatif injuste car
il ne fut pour rien dans la décision de
réprimer les meutes le entra toujours
la doctrine de l'exécutif fort la
dénonciation permanente de
l'affaiblissement et de la dégradation
de la République dont les Jeunes Turcs
se sont faits les propagateurs acharnés
n'est-ce pas là l'explication du brutal
sursaut l'État et de son bilan tragique
les hommes de progrès et d'innovation
sont devenus des fusilleurs
constat d'autant plus amer à Jean
Missler que cet homme lucide comprend
mieux que d'autres ce qui a été l'émeute
et la nature exacte de la menace qui
pesait sur la République
pour l'opinion en général mais surtout
pour la mémoire collective de la gauche
le 6 février fut un jour de danger
mortel pour les institutions
parlementaires la thèse la plus répandue
a été celle d'un complot destinée à
briser la République et à lui substituer
un autre système monarchique ou fasciste
il ne sait exactement
mais jean-mystère pressant que cette
analyse est fausse il sait d'instin que
les meute ne recouvraient aucun dessin
précis aucune conjuration organisée
certes depuis 1932 l'indignation
populaire face à la combinaison des
scandales et de l'impuissance de la
classe politique a été soigneusement
tatisée et les extrémistes ont multiplié
les annathèmes et les exhortations tous
laissés présager le vaste sursaut
populaire qui balayerait un jour un
parti radical accusé de conduire la
France au désastre
l'instinct politique de jean-micheler
lui dit très tôt que l'agitation des
années 1932-1934 et l'émeutes du 6
février son tout bonnement l'assaut
donné à la majorité radicale par les
vaincus politiques de 1932 et un moyen
comme un autre d'arracher le pouvoir à
ceux qui l'avaient conquis dans les
urnes
parce qu'il ne croit pas au complot
délibéré contre la République
Jean-Michel éprouve la réaction
sanglante du gouvernement dont il est
membre d'y avoir été associé lui sera
toujours une aguerrissable blessure
mais jean-mystère constate aussi avec
des espoirs les conséquences de la
tragédie du 6 février sur la vie
politique française
la république parlementaire à laquelle
il croit et dès ce moment atteinte d'un
mal fatal elle ne sait plus elle ne veut
plus se défendre le suicide qui sera
accompli le 10 juillet 1940 trouve là
son commencement quand le 7 février au
matin tous ceux qui croient pourtant au
complot contre la République refuse de
la défendre et s'incline devant la rue
des chenets certes quelques hommes tel
Léon Blum les on joue tente de
convaincre dans la vie de faire front
mais leur appui peut-il compenser la
défection du Parti radical celle des
Jeunes Turcs celle d'Edouard Herriot
celle du président Lebrun
que derrière ceux qui prêchent la
nécessité de céder au désordre public se
dissimule la puissante volonté de Pierre
Laval cela épatant mais la bilité
manœuvrière de celui-ci n'aurait pas
suffi si les défenseurs naturels de la
République la majorité portait au
pouvoir par le suffrage universel avait
fermement décidé que la légalité
républicaine devait prévaloir sur les
volontés de la rue
par de l'almassacre le 6 février ouvre
une crise du régime auquel consciemment
ou non les élus ont pour la plupart
cessé de croire le gouvernement
Doumergue qui succède à celui de
Daladier consacre le succès de
l'autorité de fêtes de la rue sur
l'autorité de droit des élus
jean-micheler comprend avec quelques-uns
des Jeunes Turcs tel Pierre Mendès
France et Jean Zay et ils sont rares à
rapporter ce jugement lucide que le plus
grave réside dans cette capitulation
volontaire des élus véritable suicide
politique devant une rue dont il
surestime la force et la cohésion
refaire l'histoire est un jeu séduisant
rêvons un instant comme Antoine Blondin
annulant le traité de Westphalie
un Jean-Michel différent
si en 1934 au lieu d'être dans la foule
de ces 37 ans il avait été un homme
politique vénérable venu aux affaires
publiques au temps d'une France en
expansion et sûre d'elle-même peut-être
utile était convaincu de la capacité de
rebondissement de la République
lui faisant davantage confiance
peut-être serait-il monter le 10 juillet
1940 à bord du Massilia prêt 5 ans plus
tard a postuler les fonctions de
président du Conseil voire la
magistrature suprême
mais Jean Miss clair n’étaient pas
parvenu à l'âge de certitudes paisible
et sa connaissance du monde germanique
sa formation de germaniste l'ont sans
doute poussée à prendre en compte de
manière privilégiée la puissance
montante de l'Allemagne et
l'affaiblissement français
Jean-Michel définit clairement en 1936
sa position certains se croient
partisans de la Russie alors qu'ils sont
simplement partisans de son système
politique d'autres affiches des
sympathies pour l'Allemagne hitlérienne
alors qu'ils sont simplement partisans
d'un régime autoritaire inspiré du
National Socialisme nous devons refuser
de nous laisser entraîner dans ce
dilemme parce qu'entre les deux branches
de l'alternative communisme ou fascisme
il y a tout ce que nous aimons
c'est-à-dire la démocratie c'est-à-dire
la liberté de même quand les deux
branches du dilemme également faux ou en
prétend maintenir notre politique
étrangère quand on le dit Berlin ou
Moscou il y a précisément toute
l'organisation durable de la paix
ce double anathème jeté sur les
idéologies d'adverse mais elle
était-elle vraiment
confère à la position de Jean-Michel un
caractère bien inconfortable
les intellectuels tentent alors à se
ranger sous la bannière du seul
antifascisme et à considérer que Moscou
est la MEC de la résistance contre
Hitler entre le mal absolu du projet
hitlérien
et ce que l'on tente à décrire comme le
mal relatif du communisme revendiquant
pour lui l'indulgence au nom d'attention
supposée bonne et marquer du Saut du
progrès les choix en faveur du second
deviennent impératif
l'intellectuel doit être antifasciste ou
alors ce n'est pas un intellectuel
que l'on se souvienne de l'indignation
provoquée par Gide à son retour du RSS
que l'on se souvienne aussi du propos de
Romain Rolland
sur l'ours de la terreur malgré le
dégoût malgré l'horreur malgré les
erreurs féroces je vais à l'enfant je
prends le nouveau-né il est l'espoir
misérable de l'avenir humain
la position de jean-micheler en rupture
avec l'esprit de son temps le rang
d'emblé suspect et il a grave son cas en
tirant les conséquences de ce jugement
sur le plan des relations
internationales le pacte
franco-soviétique est un leurre dit-il
il n'a aucun caractère d'automaticité il
doit être équilibré par un grand pacte à
l'ouest qui inclurait l'Allemagne afin
de la neutraliser et de lui imposer des
comportements pacifiés
nous abordons ici la dernière partie de
cette carrière dont rien annonce encore
qu'elle va être brisée au contraire
jamais jean-misler brillamment réélu en
1936 n'est aussi écouté qu'en ces mois
précédant la guerre dont il prévoit
qu'elle entraînera pour la France un
désastre sans précédent
pour comprendre ce que fut alors ses
choix
laissez-moi mes cieux
évoquer un instant notre pays en cette
veille de conflit mondial
il est en plein déclin démographique une
population doucement vieillissante veut
ignorer ses problèmes parce qu'en vrai
Tardieu leur avait promis en 1930 une
politique de prospérité les Français
croyaient être à l'abri de la crise qui
affectait si profondément la vie des
autres pays lorsque la crise atteint la
France en 1931-1932 nul ou presque parmi
ceux qui détiennent le pouvoir et moins
encore l'opinion publique de la
perçoivent ni ne tente de s'y adapter
aussi lorsque au milieu de la décennie
le monde connaît enfin un début de
reprise la crise malconjurer
s'approfondit en France
confronté à cette réalité inattendue une
France îlot de crise dans un monde qui
peut à peu revient à la prospérité
l'opinion connaît un désarroi profond
pour elle l'État les élus et les
institutions sont coupables d'un
prévoyance et d'incapacité
se désarroi poussent les Français ou
repli sur la vie privée les conduites à
refusé de voir les nuages qui
s'amoncellent
si leur chanteur préféré proclament tel
l'écologie indé Ventura tout va très
bien Madame la marquise pendant que
brûle la château et que s'accumule les
catastrophes enchaînent et conclutent
avec Maurice Chevalier chacun sur terre
se fout ce fou des petites misères du
voisin du dessous
le 23 août 1939 la signature du pack
germano-soviétique fait l'effet d'une
bombe elle bouleverse toutes les
certitudes modifier radicalement la
situation internationale et convaincent
Missler que ses analyses étaient loin
d'être fausse en dénonçant de manière
symétrique les deux totalitarismes il
avait entrevu la solitude et démocraties
et d'abord de la France et le caractère
illusoire de l'alliance de revers si
cher au système diplomatique français
sur le plan intern aussi il voit
justifier son hostilité permanente à
l'entrée des communistes dans les
gouvernements de fonds populaires il a
eu raison contre Pierre cotte et Jacques
Kayser mais pour autant il n'a pu
imposer des choix qui lui fait de la
France un adversaire réel face à une
Allemagne dont les ambitions ne sont
plus après le pacte dissimulé
la guerre que jean-mystère et ses amis
ont si durablement tenté d'éviter là et
elle débouche en quelques mois sur la
défaite après une drôle de guerre qui
convient à la majorité des Français
encore convaincu que comme le disent
cette autre scie des années 30 nos
petites misères sont passagères tout ça
s'arrangera mais la guerre ne s'arrange
pas et conduite en quelques mois à
l'effondrement
dans cette déroute la classe politique
doit décider du sort de la France à
défaut de pouvoir assurer celui des
Français dans le débat tragique qui
divise alors les politiques jean-misler
et conséquent avec lui-même il participe
activement à un dernier combat qui
tranchera de l'avenir des institutions
contre ses anciens amis Édouard Daladier
Janzé Pierre Mendès France qui souhaite
le départ hors de France du président de
la République afin de perpétuer la
légalité républicaine et qui a défaut
s'embarque de même pour le Maroc Jean
Missler plaide pour le maintien du
pouvoir légal sur le sol français
mais ce pouvoir le président Le Brun si
désemparé en est-il le plus sûr
représentant sera-t-il le mieux à même
de parler au nom des Français un
vainqueur qui paraît en mesure de
soumettre à sa volonté le reste du
continent européen non réponse en
mystère et le 7 juillet il va avec
Pierre anti-étienne Flandin a duré le
président Lebrun de démissionner
rapporteur de la Commission du suffrage
universel c'est encore lui qui le 10
juillet 1940 présente devant le Sénat et
la Chambre des députés réunissent en
assemblée nationale l'article unique qui
va mettre fin à la Troisième République
en confiant tous les pouvoirs au
maréchal Pétain et or le changement de
premiers une nouvelle constitution
569 parlementaires sur 666 se sont
prononcés dans sa faveur
certes nombre d'entre eux déploreront
dès le lendemain un vote de désarroi
invoqueront l'incompréhension des
conséquences de ce texte mais la
majorité existe et les présidents des
deux assemblées eux-mêmes Édouard
Herriot et Jules Jeanney pourtant
profondément hostile s'abstiennent de
voter contre
les députés désemparés n'ont pas vu
derrière ce texte les volontés anti
républicaines qui entendent bien mettre
fin aux institutions parlementaires pour
y substituer un État autoritaire
homme de la Troisième République
du parti pivot de cette République
depuis la fin du 19e siècle l'un de ses
principaux espoirs
jean-mystère eu le privilège ambigu de
participer activement aux convulsions
qui en marquèrent la fin
ces choix dans les années noires que va
vivre alors la France sont le fruit de
la déception que la république
parlementaire inspire à celui qui
paraissait être jusqu'à lors un
parlementaire né il le condamneront
ensuite à renoncer à tout destin
politique
au moment où la carrière politique le
quitte car ce n'est pas lui qui s'en est
détourné
il nous faut messieurs
tenter de rassembler les idées de
Jean-Michel
en 1945 à l'heure des contes il doit
ajouter au titre de galopin sanglant
celui largement partagé au demeurant de
naufrageurs de la République
admissi siècle de générations nous
séparent désormais de la grande rupture
des années 1939-194 à regarder en
arrière avec sérénité et au bout d'un
demi-siècle cela doit être possible si
douloureuse qui était essais années on
peut considérer que les déconvenues de
Jean-Michel furent celles d'un esprit
projeté dans l'avenir plutôt que vers le
passé
certes sa volonté de sauver la paix à
tout prix tient avant tout à son
expérience la Première Guerre mondiale
au tribu paya cette guerre par le peuple
français à l'analyse qu'il fait de
l'état de la France en 1939 mais le
regard qu'il porte en ces années
désespérantes sur son pays et sur le
monde qui l'entoure est prospectif
il est des chiffres déjà les grandes
tendances de notre fin de siècle sa
critique de la faiblesse des
institutions son plaidoyer pour un État
fort
pour un contrôle public de l'économie
préfigure quelques-unes des conceptions
clés de la Cinquième République et sa
vision d'une fédération européenne dont
le couple franco-allemand serait le vrai
pilier ne reflète-t-elle pas la
construction internationale qui prévaut
aujourd'hui
peut-être dans cette vision apparemment
si complète
du monde pourrait-on néanmoins s'étonner
de l'indifférence du manque de curiosité
de Jean-Michel pour une part non
négligeable de l'Europe son flanc
oriental
de manière étonnante hillaryé le monde
slave de sa réflexion et de sa vie il
l'a voulu même tout l'intérêt de
l'univers à l'exception des Slaves
ironie de l'histoire veut que ce
monde-là soit celui qui passionne son
successeur mais cet homme d'humour est
sourit j'en suis certaine devant un tour
comme le sort nous en joue parfois
autant toujours dit que le monde n'est
de la Révolution 1917 s'en émancipe et
dresse les foyables bilans du communisme
que les victimes disent haut et forts
qu'à totalitarisme rouge ou brun quelle
que soit ses intentions affichées n'est
jamais qu'un totalitarisme donc un crime
contre l'homme
comment ne pas songer à la condamnation
égale et sans appel que porte Jean
Missler du communisme aussi bien que du
fascisme
ses propos jusqu'à scandaleux au cours
des années 30 voir quelques décennies
plus tard sont aujourd'hui raison
communes
ils ont pourtant contribué à nourrir la
réprobation silencieuse qui peut sur lui
quand en 1945 dans une France
Renaissance mais durablement meurtrie
Jean-Michel contemple son passé il peut
à bon droit considéré que son destin est
déjà accompli la politique lui est
fermée il n'y a pas de retraite en
politique on meurt où l'on devient un
mort-vivant et critique de cela il ne
serait pour lui être question il
n’entend pas lui qui fut homme de
gouvernement se transformer en demi-sol
des gris en nostalgie des occasions
perdues ou en opposant de métier il
nourrit de l'amertume il latait il
n'accepte pas qu'elle paralyse les choix
qu'il doit faire
à l'heure de l'isolement cet homme dont
la vocation est d'être heureux voit
venir à lui le passé et l'amitié pour
reconstruire sa vie
avec l'aide d'un ami le parlementaire
devient éditeur et font les éditions du
Rocher il donne dans le même temps à
l'aurore autre portes ouvertes par
l'amitié des chroniques littéraires et
musicales d'une grande finesse puis
comme s'il fallait de manière visible
fermer la parenthèse la vie publique il
prend la responsabilité du livre
français à l'étranger le haut
fonctionnaire a pris ses droits mais la
littérature les reprend aussi
le troisième temps de sa vie il sera
long près de quatre décennies y est
consacré l'homme qui avance vers la
maturité renoue ainsi avec le jeune
homme qui rôde et rétabli par la grâce
d'une oeuvre multiforme à l'image d'une
personnalité aussi riche que contraster
l'unité d'un destin malmenée par
l'histoire
accueillante il y a près d'un quart de
siècle jean-micheler en ce lieu même
Marcel Brion le définissait tout à la
fois par le romantisme et par l'héritage
de Voltaire
romantique sans aucun doute Jean mystère
l’était Petri de culture et de musique
de cet Allemagne romantique dont il fut
si proche amoureux des paysages de forêt
et de brume des châteaux enchantés de
Bavière il a choisi de vivre une part de
sa vie et de son œuvre dans ce monde où
rêve et réel se côtoient et se
confondent parfois jusqu'à la folie et
la mort il n'est dès leur guerre
surprenant qu'il est consacré beaucoup
de temps à un écrivain allemand du 19e
siècle en kil littérature et musique
s'incarne et dont il a dans un livre
semblés prolonger la tradition je veux
parler d'Hoffmann
en 1927 déjà alors que la politique le
sollicitait Jean-Michel a publié une vie
d'Hoffmann qui sera très vite épuisée
témoignage de la curiosité inquiète
qu'inspire alors l'Allemagne à notre
pays en 1950 qu'en tournant le dos à son
passé politique il s'en revient à la
littérature cette offre maintenant
encore qui rouvre ce chapitre de sa vie
ce n'est pas par hasard
retournant après tant d'années dans une
Allemagne en ruine où la folie
meurtrière d'Hitler semble avoir eu pour
conséquence première la destruction de
tous les lieux de mémoire Jean mystère
s'attache à réhabiliter le souvenir de
ceux qui dit-il ont payé pour Hitler
Hoffman Goeth et Wagner
parce que l'embrasement général de
l'Allemagne aura été à l'image du
romantisme prend un débouché sur la
folie et l'autodestruction parce que le
revendise m'y revêt la dimension du
fantastique Jean-Michel dans ce second
of Man et part de la Hoffmann livre ici
un code de lecture du génie allemand il
voit bien ce qui fait la singularité du
romantisme allemand est-ce qu'il sépare
du génie français à savoir que le
désordre des esprits est total alors
qu'en France le mal du siècle est
allègrement vécu par ceux par les
écrivains qui s'en font les chantres le
délir mystique de Werner la folie de
kolderline le suicide de Claes la fein
tragique d'Hoffmann n'auront eu que de
très tardives équivalents en France par
exemple avec Nerval en France ce conflit
tragique entre le rêve et la vie entre
l'ombre et la lumière entre la folie et
la raison restera généralement quand on
est aux oeuvres sans affecter les vies
c'est le 4 Jean-Michel dont l'oeuvre
n'est pas si éloignée de celle de Man
dans le fantastique Irène en maître de
la maison du docteur cliffton aux orques
de Saint-Sauveur et surtout aux
nouvelles de l'ami des pauvres il
apparaît comme un des rares
représentants du fantastique français
mais Jean-Michel est aussi l'enfant de
sores d'une terre de raison il n'accepte
jamais de s'abandonner complètement à
l'irréel Sylvain en permanence du rêve
ou réel il projette sur l'avenir de
l'absurde et de la folie le requin
équilibré contrôlé que les Dominicains
seraient aussi fort contribué à
développer chez eux dont chez ce dont
ils ont la charge
héritier de Voltaire disait Marcel Brion
cela est exa aussi la femme nue
savoureuse aventure d'un copiste qui
invente un Vermeer est un conte
philosophique dans la plus pure
tradition volcanienne le mystère la
confusion entre le vrai et l'imaginaire
explique aussi la curiosité de
Jean-Michel pour gasparaser dans cette
exploration d'une destinée singulière il
apporte tout à la fois la rigueur de
l'universitaire et une familiarité
totale avec le milieu ouakil énigme
l'Allemagne romantique
qui a lu ce livre et bien prête
comprendre ce que sera nurember un
siècle plus tard et la fascination des
foules pour ces cathédrales de lumière
qui dissimulait hélas un monstrueux
dessin
les livres consacrés à la musique aux
musiciens qui sont une par essentielle
du monde de Jean-Michel ne sont pas en
marge de l'oeuvre ils sont le ciment
unifie tous les défis et le fait tenir
il n'est pas sans intérêt de constater
qu'un ouvrage consacré aux musiciens
s'intitule aimé des dieux ne sont-ils
pas en effet de tous les créateurs les
plus aimés de Dieu se demandent-ils et
il envoie confirmation dans le destin
prématurément et brutalement arrêté des
génies qu'il rêvèrent Mozart Weber
wolfberg et quelques autres le lien
qu'il établit entre l'amour jaloux des
dieux pour ceux qui ont le plus comblé
et le prix que ceux-ci sont appelés à
payer pour les dons reçus jette aussi
une certaine lumière sur un sujet
difficile
sujet que le respect pour la réserve
qu'il manifesta toujours en ce domaine
interdit d'approfondir ces rapports avec
Dieu
certes n'étaient pas où n'étaient plus
que l'on appelle un croyant mais comment
ne pas évoquer devant ce lien établi
entre l'amour les dons exceptionnels
reçus des dieux et la dette ainsi
contractée Jacques Maritain Dieu est
implacable et exige tout de ce qu'il
aime infiniment comment ne pas souvenir
de sa dévotion un Sorèze comment oublier
sa révolte contre une fois dégradée par
les modes ou tout simplement par sa
transformation en habitude si les
prêtres disaient la messe une fois par
mois si les Faudel fidèles communaient
une fois par an ils y feraient davantage
attention ne sont pas là parole d'une
âme inquiète et exigeante
je sais messieurs que je n'ai fait là
que survoler l’œuvre de Jean-Michel mais
je n'ai voulu tenter que de faire
revivre devant vous un homme tout entier
avec toutes ses vies celle de l'action
de l'Esprit et de l'oeuvre c'est
pourquoi il est encore une part
essentiel sur laquelle il me faut
m'arrêter celles qui se confond avec
votre compagnie
après ce qu'il nomme avec Alain les
moments supprimés de la vie
l'Académie fut en effet pour lui le port
où il trouva tout à la fois la paix
intérieure l'oubli d'une carrière brisée
et surtout la manifestation de
précieuses amitiés élus en 1966 puis
portait en 1973 au responsabilités de
secrétaire perpétuel
jean-mystère ne cessa pas de constater
que l'Académie était le lieu où les
tourments les meurtrissures ou les
regrets pouvaient trouver à s'estomper
peut-être est-ce parce que le destin
politique est précaire cruelle au vaincu
qui leur a été si sensible à ce qu'il
appelait l'esprit de famille et la
mémoire de l'Académie famille que nous
divise aucun conflit d'héritage et qui
souffre de la disparition des siens qui
se souvient d'eux et les inscrits à
jamais dans sa tradition
quant au soir de cette vie qui fut
longue les chagrins privés
s'accumulèrent
l'enfant morte la maladie de celle qui
l'accompagna toujours l'épuisement
personnel jean-mystère fifase avec un
stoïcisme souriant et courtois à ses
créances que Dieu venait présenter au
jeune homme qui rôde pour prit des dons
qui avaient été les siens si le renonça
par dignité sagesse à une charge qui
l'estimait ne plus pouvoir remplir
pleinement l'Académie n'en reste pas
moins son ultime consolation il s'était
donné totalement à elle depuis le jour
elle l'avait accueilli il y avait été
heureux c'était le lieu où le malheur
lui était le plus supportable
au terme de ce parcours je voudrais
messieurs tenter de rassembler en
quelques mots cet homme que sans l'avoir
jamais rencontré j'ai grâce à vous
découvert je commencerai en citant le
père carré
cet être d'exception qui était à soi
seul un monde toute sa vie ou plutôt
toutes ses vies toutes son œuvre
témoignent de la justesse d'un tel
propos comme les musiciens qu'il
vénérait jean-micheler fut sans aucun
doute aimer des dieux il leur doit cette
personnalité ou s'équilibre selon la
belle formule de Marcel Brion le
classique né et le romantique
d'aspiration il leur doit cette
intelligence pénétrante et cette
sensibilité que la musique a nourrit
homme de culture incomparable prototype
de l'homme cultivé tel qu'il existait
dans cette Europe civilisée du 19e
siècle qui lui était si familière il fut
aussi malgré une apparente froideur et
un certain détachement un homme de
passion en dépit des revers et des
chagrins il constatait en se retournant
vers son passé qu'il pouvait prétendre
ne rien regretter de ce qui fut son sort
au hasard d'une rencontre avec une amie
universitaire choyée comme il lui peut
l'être si le jeune homme qui rôde
n'avait couru tant de chemins aventureux
il concluait combien ai-je rencontrer
d'ennuis dans ma destinée mais que
l'ennui que la sienne
l'amertume certes ne fut pas absente de
ses réflexions sur un destin inégal mais
cette amertume fut toujours voilée de
courtoisie vie œuvre confondues nul ne
serait affirmé que jean-micheler fut
victime aux heures noires de la seule
malchance qu'il ne s'est jamais trompé
mais il était porté vers ses choix par
une expérience et une vision dont le
présent nous montre sur le long terme
qu'elle n'était pas dénuée de
justification
que ce rêveur cet esprit s'y enclin a
scruter l'invisible à peut-être par
cette proportion perçue que l'Europe
serait un jour la grande œuvre de la
France c'est là en dernier ressort le
sens de l'oeuvre que d'un livre à
l'autre il a laissé à ses contemporains
de cette longue vie de ses idées que
l'histoire aura heurté brisée parfois
sans doute faut-il retenir la vision
prospective d'une Europe de l'esprit et
la volonté de contribuer à son
édification
parcourant ce siècle avec Jean-Michel
j'ai souvent évoqué l'Europe
il me faut pourtant dire que cette
Europe dont l'Allemagne et la frontière
n'est pas tout à fait la mienne il est
manque de stoïevski Pouchkine Gogol
l'Ermont of tourgagna Tolstoï mais aussi
michkawich et petophis Kafka et panaïté
strati et combien d'autres
j'appartiens messieurs à une génération
qui arrivait à l'adolescence au sortir
de la dernière guerre fut confronté au
malheur européen
l'Europe amputée d'une part d'elle-même
l'Occident kidnappé comme la plaie Milan
Kundera ce fut là notre horizon
nous savions que le passé y était aboli
que la pensée les génies que je viens
d'évoquer n'avaient droit de citer que
pour autant qu'il contribue à légitimer
l'utopie meurtrière nous savions tout
peuple arraché à la civilisation commune
dizaine de milliers de millions de nos
semblables plongés dans l'enfer glacée
des camps et par dessus tout peut-être
l'horrible et dégradante obligation fait
à tous de proclamer que ce malheur était
le véritable bonheur
à ma modeste place celle de l'historien
je me suis efforcé de contribuer au
maintien de la mémoire de ses hommes et
de ses peuples qui en était privés
j'ai tenté par optimisme naturel
peut-être mais d'abord parce que le cœur
et la raison se refusaient à accepter
l'inacceptable il inhumain de déchiffrer
un avenir ou l'Europe se recomposerait
dans la liberté
ce rêve que nous avons tous partagé il
est aujourd'hui réalisé
certes tout n'est pas simple de ce
printemps des peuples qui n'en finit pas
d'éclore et l'habitude de la haine
nourrit encore bien des conflits mais
l'essentiel est écartant les décombres
des hommes de bonne volonté tentent en
dépit du chaos et de la misère de
reconstruire un univers ou la digue été
humaine retrouve sa place
vous m'accueillez messieurs parmi vous
au moment même où s'accomplit ce
bouleversement miraculeux
c'est là une grâce supplémentaire que je
vous dois par là ce que j'ai tenté de
faire ce que j'ai tenté d'être ce à quoi
j'ai toujours cru trouve peut-être une
justification de cela messieurs je ne
serai assez vous remercier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]